[Music]
welcome back to harvard unboxed today i
am finally able to show you how the
radeon rx 6800 xt performs
and i've also got the standard 6800 on
hand as well so there will be a
dedicated review of this model
on the channel shortly there is a lot to
cover so i wanted to give each of them
their own dedicated review
for those of you who may have been
living under a rock for the past few
weeks
the 6800 xt is amd's new high-end gaming
graphics card
targeting the geforce rtx 3080.
basically amd's claiming 3080 light
performance
for a 50 discount while offering
considerably more vram
at 16 gigabytes versus just 10 gigabytes
for the geforce card
i'm not going to pour over all the specs
again as we covered that in our
announcement video
in short the 6800 xt is set to come in
at 650
us it's based on the new rdna 2
architecture using tsmc's 7 nanometer
process
it packs 4608 cores 288 tmus and 128
rops across
72 cus the cores clock it up to 2250
megahertz and then we have 16 gigabytes
of
16 gigabits per second gddr6 memory on a
256 bit wide memory bus
allowing for 512 gigabytes per second of
memory bandwidth
the card's rated at 300 watts for the
total board power
and of course it supports pci express
4.0
there's some new features here as well
such as ray tracing support 128
megabytes of amd infinity cache and
shared access memory amd also has a new
reference card design which looks
significantly better than anything we've
seen from them before
so without wasting any time let's talk
about the test system and then jump into
the blue bar graphs
as i know that's what most of you are
here for once again i'll be testing with
my ryzen 9
3950x test system and yes i will be
updating to the 5950x
as soon as i can updating all of this
data will take a solid
two to three weeks of nothing but
testing so it's not going to happen
overnight but it is something i'll be
working on as soon as i can
basically once i get through all these
new products it is worth noting though
the 3950x has very little influence on
the 1440p data
and it doesn't limit the 4k results in
any way so for the most part
very little will change by moving to the
5950x anyway
okay let's get into the results starting
with godfall at 1440p we
find very strong performance from the
6800 xt
here it beat the rtx 3080 by a 14 margin
are coming right behind
the 30 90. then when compared to the
5700 xt
we're talking about a 92 increase in
frame rate
going from 52 fps right up to a 100 fps
so that's a pretty incredible jump right
there of course the 6800 xt is a much
more expensive product
but the 5700 xt was considered to be
amd's flagship gaming gpu from the
previous generation
jumping up to 4k does see the 6800 xt
lose some ground
to the 3090 though even here it still
managed to match the rtx 3080
so not bad given that it is slightly
cheaper we are also looking at 60 fps
performance at 4k
in what is a very visually impressive
title
whereas godfall is an amd sponsored
title watchdog's legion is an nvidia
sponsored title
but even so the radeon rx 6800 xt still
impressed at 1440p matching the rtx 3080
with 85 fps on average
using the highest visual quality
settings the game has to offer
that said at 4k we are seeing
performance slip a little bit or rather
the 3080 scales better at high
resolutions
the 6800xt actually scales as expected
and is in line with the 2080 ti for
example
anyway the end result being an 11 loss
to the 3080 at 4k
placing the 6800 xt between the 3080 and
3070.
the 6800 xt performs exceptionally well
in assassin's creed valhalla
beating even the 3090 by a rather
convincing 14
margin at 1440p it is possible nvidia
will improve performance in this title
with future driver updates
but for now amd enjoys a serious
performance advantage
that said the ampere gpus are able to
catch up at 4k and now the 6800xt finds
itself situated between the rtx 3080
and 3090 which is still a mighty
impressive result
it's just less impressive than what was
seen at 1440p
dirt 5 is another new amd sponsored
title and here the radeon gpus really do
clean up
the 6800 xt was 18 faster than the 3090
and 30 faster than the 3080. that
is a staggering difference and i expect
at some point in video we'll be able to
make up
some of that difference with a future
driver how long that will take though it
is hard to say it did take them
quite some time before they addressed
the low than expected performance in
forza horizon 4 for example moving to 4k
though we again find a situation where
the ampere gpus kick into gear
and here they managed to make up quite a
bit of ground on the 6800 xt
even so the rd and a2 gpu was still five
percent faster than the 3090
and 16 percent faster than the 3080
next up we have death stranding and
again we're seeing some very impressive
results out of the 6800 xt
at 1440p here it's able to match the
nudging it ever so slightly ahead of the
3080.
even at 4k the performance is still very
good and although the 6800xt does slip
behind the rtx 3080 we're only looking
at a 5
deficit and with over 100 fps on average
i doubt anyone is going to complain
with that kind of performance at 4k the
microsoft flight simulator 2020 results
at 1440p are quite good
here we're looking at an almost 60
performance improvement over the 5700 xt
averaging 51 fps which more crucially
placed it on par with the rtx 3080
however once again we're seeing a
situation
where at 4k performance does slide quite
considerably
and now the 6800 xt is 18 slower than
the 3080.
still when compared to the 5700 xt it is
faster and that's obviously a serious
performance improvement
moving on to shadow of the tomb raider
here the 6800 xt trailed the rtx 3080 by
a few frames at 1440p though we're
basically talking about the same level
of performance
as there's no chance you'll notice the
difference between 151
and 154 fps again though we're seeing
the 6800 xt fall short at 4k
this time trailing the rtx 3080 by an 8
margin not a huge difference
and 79 fps on average at 4k is still a
very impressive in this title
frame rates in tom clancy's rainbow six
siege are very competitive as the 6800
xt offered rtx 3080 light performance
nudging ahead by 3 at 1440p to pump out
337 fps on average
the 6800 xt also remains strong at 4k
here it was capable of rendering 168 fps
on average
making it just three percent slower than
the rtx 3080 so in other words
the same level of performance the f1
2020 results are also massively
impressive as here the 6800 xt
is once again seen delivering rtx 3080
light performance
and with 197 fps on average it was 55
faster than the 5700 xt at 1440p
increasing the resolution of 4k so the
6800 xt beat the older 5700 xt by a
whopping
72 percent margin though despite that
increase it was a little slower than the
rtx 3080 but still
overall a great result and i'd argue
that 120 plus
fps at 4k and f1 2020 is plenty
moving on to the gears 5 testing and
here we're again seeing a very strong
1440p performance from the 6800 xt as it
managed to edge out even the rtx 3090
though we will be running into a bit of
a cpu bottleneck here with the ryzen
93950x
and yes when i get a bit more time i
will spend over a week
updating the data with the 5950x again
we're seeing the 6800xt slip at 4k
or rather more accurately the higher
core count amp gpus
come to life at 4k either way though the
end result being a 12
performance deficit in favor of the rtx
horizon zero dawn ran very well on the
6800xt
1440p again delivering rtx 3080 light
performance
which just two months ago now was the
kind of performance that really blew our
minds
we do see the six hour xt4 behind the
rtx 3080 by 10 margin at 4k
so it's less impressive relative to the
geforce competition at this extreme
resolution
but even so we're talking about an
almost eighty percent improvement over
the 5700 xt
the assassin's creed odyssey results are
quite different to those seen in the
newer valhalla title
interestingly at 1440p the 600xt is
rendering fewer frames per second in
odyssey
whereas the ampere gpus are rendering
more as a result the 6800xt was five
percent slower at 1440p
when compared to the rtx 3080 and just
29 faster than the 5700 xt
then we see quite unexpectedly that the
600xt manages to overtake the 3080 at 4k
so scaling here is at odds with
everything that we've seen previously
now the 6800 xt is 5 faster than 3080
and
71 faster than the 5700 xt
next up we have world war z and here the
6800 xt finds itself situated between
the 30 90 and 3080 at 1440p
beating the ladder by a nine percent
margin with 207 fps on average
here we have yet another example at 4k
where the 6800xt
is able to pull further ahead of the
3080 this time beating it by a 14
margin are coming just behind the rtx
3090 so a very impressive result there
unfortunately we are running into a
slight cpu bottleneck in metro exodus at
1440p with these higher end gpus
and again while i do plan to swap to the
5950x as soon as i can
that testing will require a lot of time
the 4k
data though is in no way cpu limited and
here the 1600 xt does fall behind the
3080 by 15
margin which is quite a substantial
difference
though 105 fps on average at 4k is still
quite impressive
testing with resident evil 3 shows the
6800 xt trailing the rtx 3080 by a 3
margin at 1440p so we're basically
receiving the same level of performance
that's a pretty incredible 92
performance uplift over the 5700 xt
and the 27 boost over nvidia's previous
generation flagship part the
2080 ti then at 4k the 6800 xt is 6
percent slower than the rtx 3080 so
not a huge margin and again you're
unlikely to ever notice this sort of a
difference
but this is also more evidence that the
rtx 3080 is a little better suited to 4k
gaming
do maternal sees the 6800 xt pumping out
over
300 fps at 1440p to deliver rtx 38d
light performance
and that meant it was 72 percent faster
than the 5700 xt
and radeon 7 gpus and that massive 16
gigabyte vrm buffer comes in handy at 4k
with the ultra nightmare texture quality
as it allowed the 6800 xt to beat the
5700 xt by a whopping 127
margin performance relative to the
high-end amp
gpus was also very good as the 1600xt
trailed the 3080 by just a 7
margin the second last game we're going
to look at is wolfenstein
young blood and at 1440p we're seeing
241 fps from the 6800 xt
making it just four percent slower than
the rtx 3080.
incredibly this is yet another title
where we're seeing over a 90
performance uplift from the 5700 xt
and the 6800 xt is just as impressive at
4k
despite losing ground to the rtx 3080
which as we've seen time and time again
now typically comes alive at this high
resolution
as it's able to better load up all of
those cores still the 600xt was just
nine percent slower and with 137 fps on
average performance was still quite
impressive
the last game tested is hitman 2 and
like metro exodus we are running into a
cpu bottleneck at 1440p
with the 3950x the 4k data though isn't
limited by the cpu and here the 6800xt
was seen to be 8
slower than the rtx 3080 which is a
fairly typical margin at this resolution
speaking of typical margins here's a
look at the average performance
seen across the 18 games tested although
we didn't spend time looking at the
1080p data in this review
i did collect it and those graphs will
be made available to patreon and
floatplane members
but to save time though here's a look at
the 1080p average data and as you can
see at this low resolution the 600 xt
fares
very well just edging out the rtx 3090
to beat the 3080 by a6
margin so fairly similar performance
across those three gpus
now 1440p the 6800xt slips behind the
3090 by 5
margin but it is still just ahead of the
rtx 3080 by a three percent margin
so in other words performance is much
the same as anything within a five
percent margin i typically deem to be a
tie
when compared to the 5700 xt we're
looking at a 67
performance increase on average which is
good but not amazing given it costs a
little over 60
more then at 4k as we often saw the rtx
3080 fares a little bit better here
overall though the 6800 xt was just five
percent slower
and the margin to the 5700 xt opens up
quite a lot
here the new rdna 2 gpu was 86 percent
faster
and that's obviously quite a substantial
performance uplift even when taking the
price into account
speaking of the price here's a look at
the cost per frame and i'll start by
using the 1080p data
when compared to the rtx 3080 the 6800
xt costs 12
less per frame while it comes in at an 8
premium over the rtx 3070
though it is worth noting that cost
analysis doesn't account for the fact
that the radeon gpu packs twice as much
vram
we're also seeing a similar price
premium over the 5700 xt but again twice
as much vram and a higher performance
tier
the cost per frame for the 6800 xt
relative to parts such as the 5700 xt
does improve at 1440p
and it does so for two reasons it's
really a double whammy as the higher
resolution means we're seeing
fewer cpu limited scenarios with more
chance of loading up all of those cores
on these higher end gpus as a result the
6800xt is now one of the best value gpus
on the market
alongside the rtx 3070 it comes in
costing nine percent less per frame when
compared to the rtx 3080
and is a substantial improvement over
similarly priced previous generation
products such as the rtx 2080 super
then at 4k we're seeing similar
performance and value from the 6800 xt
and rtx 3080.
they're very much neck and neck here so
you wouldn't necessarily pick one over
the other
based on price or performance features
that may sway you one way or the other
includes stuff like ray tracing
performance
though personally i care very little for
ray tracing support right now as there
are almost no games
where i feel it's worth enabling that
being the case for this review i haven't
invested too much time in testing ray
tracing performance and perhaps this is
something we'll explore more in future
content
in the meantime here's how they compare
and shut off the tomb raider one of the
first rtx titles to receive ray tracing
support
so it comes as a little surprise to
learn that the geforce rtx graphics
cards perform
much better here though i would note
that the almost 40 hit to performance
with the rtx 3080 seen at 1440p
is completely unacceptable for slightly
better shadows
the 6800 xt fares even worse dropping
almost 50 percent of its original
performance
again not particularly surprising to see
our dna 2 making out more poorly
in an nvidia rtx sponsored title
another game with pointless ray traced
shadow effects is dirt 5.
though here we are only seeing a 20 hit
to performance
and i say only as i'm comparing it to
the performance hits we see in other
titles supporting ray traced fx
the performance hit here is similar for
all three gpus tested
the 6800 xt is just starting from much
further ahead
at this point i'm not really sure what
to make of the 600 xt's ray tracing
performance
i imagine i'll end up being just as
underwhelmed as i was by the geforce
experience a new feature that i find far
more exciting than ray tracing
at least in the short term is smart
access memory or
sam what amd is doing here is taking
advantage of a pci express feature
called base address register
which defines how much of your graphics
card's vram can be mapped
typically systems are limited to 256
megabytes of mapped vrm but with rdna 2
and the new ryzen 5000 series of
processors amd's enabled this feature
giving the cpu full access to the
graphics card's vram buffer
now before we get in the data i should
note that this feature doesn't improve
performance in all games
and the margins will vary depending on
the title
nvidia has also recently come out and
said that they will be enabling sam with
a new driver soon
and they've got it working on both amd
and intel platforms in their labs
anyway i'll talk more about this feature
later in the video for now let's take a
look at performance using the ryzen 9
5950x
starting with assassin's creed valhalla
we're seeing some pretty incredible
things with sam enabled 1080p we're
looking at a 17
performance boost in this title that's a
remarkable uplift and it means the 6800
xt is now
53 faster than the rtx 3080 at this
resolution
at 1440p we're still looking at a strong
performance uplift this time the frame
rate is improved by 14
and that meant the 6800 xt was 40 faster
than the rtx 3080.
40 faster at 1440p that is pretty crazy
we're also looking at a 15 performance
improvement at 4k and that means whereas
the 6800xt was able to roughly match the
rtx 3080 previously
with sam enabled it's now 13 faster
however it is worth noting that the
effects of sam are less significant in
rainbow six siege
but we're still getting a further five
percent performance at 1080p
and that further widened the gap to the
rtx 3080. the margin was reduced to four
percent at 1440p
but again that's an extra four percent
performance for nothing and then we're
seeing just a two percent boost at 4k
the gains in shadow of the tomb raider
are similar to those seen in rainbow six
siege at 1080p we're looking at a six
percent boost
though that was enough to pull the 6800
xt ahead of the rtx 3080
then we see a six percent boost at 1440p
and just 3
at 4k so again not amazing gains in this
title but it is still extra performance
at no real cost
now whereas the rtx 3080 features a
total board power rating of 320 watts
the 600 xt is a slightly more
conservative 300 watts
when comparing the amd reference model
to nvidia's foundation version
we're seeing a 40 watt reduction in
total system usage
going in amd's favor so while the 600 xt
is still a very power hungry gpu
it appears to be far more power
efficient than past amd gpus
such as the 5700 xt using nvidia's pcat
we see that the 600 xt consumes around
nine percent less power than the rtx
3080 which depending on the resolution
will give it a similar performance
per watt rating it's also interesting to
note that while the 600 xt consumed 19
more power than the 5700 xt it was often
well over 50 percent faster so an
impressive improvement there for
power efficiency and here we see in
terms of performance per what the 6800
xt
is just over a 50 improvement when
compared to the 5700 xt
and a slight improvement over the rtx
so as we found with the ampere gpus
despite being very power hungry
the performance is strong enough that
they come out looking very good in terms
of performance per watt
another area where amd has improved
massively is with their reference design
this is something we've
basically been begging them to sort out
for about a decade now
unlike previous dustbuster designs the
6800 xt reference card is cool and quiet
after an hour and shut off the tomb
raider at 4k the card peaked at just 75
degrees with a fan speed of just 1600
rpm
and that is seriously good performance
that sees amd set the bar very high for
their partners
but given the card isn't some gigantic
massive rtx 3090 founders edition
i feel they should be able to rise to
the occasion
just quickly let's talk about
overclocking by default the reference
card operated at 2
200 megahertz and shoved the tomb raider
after an hour with the frequency
increased
to 2 500 megahertz in the what man
software
the clock speed in game was increased to
365 megahertz on average so a seven and
a half percent frequency increase which
generally netted me about a five percent
fps boost in games
so pretty uneventful really hopefully
aib models will have higher power limits
for more
oc headroom okay so that is the radeon
rx
6800 xt seems pretty good to me
performance is obviously excellent and
it's quite shocking to think that just
two months ago now the rtx 3080
completely blew us away with its
performance
so that being the case i wasn't i have
to admit i wasn't overly confident amd
could pull this one off
but for the first time in a long time
they've caught nvidia
and are genuinely offering a better
value product
depending on your preferences as
expected depending on the game and even
the quality settings used the 6800 xt
and rtx 3080 trade blows
so it's very difficult to pick a clear
winner they're both so evenly matched
the main advantage though of the geforce
gpu as i see it is the more mature ray
tracing support and of course dlss 2.0
though both are questionable features
and in our opinion aren't major selling
points unless you play a specific
selection of games
basically what i mean by that is the
game support list is just too limited
dlss 2.0 is amazing it's just not enough
games
there are even less games where you can
really enjoy ray traced effects
the best aaa implementations that we've
seen so far at least in our opinion
is watchdog's legion and control though
again the performance hit is massive
but at least you can notice the effects
in those titles
the advantage of the 6800 xt includes a
much larger vram buffer sam support and
a slight
price decrease the 16 gigabyte vrm
buffer is almost certainly going to
prove beneficial down the track
think just one to two years support for
sam is another big one
though right now it is limited to those
using a ryzen 5000 series processor
on a 500 series motherboard this might
also end up being a limited time only
exclusive for amd
if nvidia are to be believed and i don't
doubt that the green team is madly
scrambling
to get this one working with ampy gpus
and that's a good thing as it will force
amd to open up support to all users
on that note i should make mention that
pci express 4.0 doesn't appear to be a
requirement for sam either
i ran a few quick tests in assassin's
creed valhalla while forcing pcie 3.0 on
our x570 motherboard
and i didn't see a decline in
performance when compared to pcie 4.0 so
that was interesting
the testing at this point is very
limited so it is something we will need
to explore further
with a little more time up our sleeves
also again i should note that the
performance gains offered by sam
vary quite a lot depending on the game
and in some titles
there's no gains to be seen at all and
this was the case in titles such as
horizon zero dawn
and watch dogs for example but i haven't
tested all 18 games yet again
just due to time moving on it was great
to see amd finally nail
the reference design it's a genuinely
good product now
and i'd have no issue using this in my
own pc
that said this time next week board
partners will be launching their own
custom models
therefore i'd personally wait and see
what's on offer there chances are you'll
be able to buy an even cooler
and quieter model with higher power
limits for overclocking
as for availability all indicators point
to horrid stock levels for this initial
wave of reference models
the release date for custom cards is the
25th so a week from now and
while i'm hearing stock levels are
better for those models there's no way
they're not going to sell out in seconds
i'd suggest you expect availability pain
until at least december
and that's just powerful of course with
these popular gpu releases
i'd also expect amd to be on top of the
demand within two months though
and if not it'll be another amp-like
disaster
basically amd's been given a rare
opportunity here to steal away nvidia
customers
who have been desperate for rtx 3080
performance
for months now they've likely only got a
narrow window though to pounce so it
will be
interesting to see if they squander that
opportunity and there's almost
no chance those who sold their rtx 2080
tis in
anticipation of the 3080 and they've
just been left there hitting refresh
hoping to
hoping to better buy one that they're
not going to just snap up a 6800 xt
faster than you can say just buy it of
course that is assuming good
availability of the 6800 xt
and there's really no reason not to buy
the 6800xt over the rtx 3080 should both
of them be available in many ways the
radeon gpu is the superior product
and that being the case it is crazy to
think how
far ahead nvidia were with products such
as pascal
only to squander that lead in what seems
like a
well a very intel like way let's say and
now that amd's well and truly caught up
you can expect the gpu wars to get very
interesting
and that's going to do it for my first
look at the radeon rx
6800 xt tomorrow i will have a detailed
6800 review
and then on the 25th we can start
reviewing board partner cards
and then early next month of course we
will have the 6900xt
so plenty more to come make sure you
subscribed and again if you enjoyed this
video
you know what to do much appreciated for
all our hard work
also you can join us over on floatplane
or patreon if you'd like to become part
of the harbour and box community
there are a few cool perks there such as
our exclusive discord chat tim and
myself are
active on that we also do a monthly live
stream for our patreon members
q a's behind the scenes videos a lot of
cool stuff there if you're interested
links for that stuff is in the video
description
if not perfectly fine i would like to
just thank you for watching this video
i'm your host steve and i'll see you
again next time
[Music]
you